それから人格者になるのはどうすればいいかという偈に入ります
このすべての香りよりも優れている香りは道徳的であること
シーラであること 戒律ですと
なんでまた香りが来たんですかというと
やっぱりこの香りの偈だからね
では 例えば白檀の香りは逆風には行かないわ
伽羅の香りも逆風には行かない
ジャスミンの香りにも逆風には
そんな弱い香りじゃなくて
最高な香りがあるんだよと
道徳的という それがもう逆風関係なく四方八方に行く
というか十方ですけどね
十方にも届くと だから答えとっても簡単
単純シンプルでしょう
道徳的になることなんです
そんな難しい到達しにくいものじゃないでしょうに
非道徳的な人間になっていいわけないでしょうに
異論立たないでしょうに
非道徳的で何が悪いんですかと
倫理道徳を破って何が悪いんでしょうかと
それ自体わがままいい加減でしょうに
何が悪いんじゃなくて
勝手にやりなさいと あんたは社会にはいらんやという話でしょうに
社会から追い出されたら生きていられないでしょうに
もともと人間弱いんだから
決して独立して一人で孤独で生きることはできません
不可能ですよ 魚は水からもう陸に上げておいたって生きていられないでしょうに
魚なら水の中でしか生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
その魚 その水をよがしたり
汚したり 毒を入れたりすると
話にならないでしょうに
だから非道徳っていうのは
もう魚がもうボンボン自分住んでいる水に毒をまくっていうような感じなんです
そうすると他の魚が寄ってこないしね
餌も餌もなくなるんです
自分の毒で自分が死ぬ羽目になっちゃうんです
具体的にそういう魚は世の中にいません
だからね あの魚のようにこの魚のようにということはちょっと言いにくいんですけど
まあ電気ウナギはいますけどね
電気ウナギも触ったら体に触れたらもう電気を出すんであって
でなきゃ出しません 日本でやる電気ウナギというんですかね
触るとかなり電気ショックです
フグもいっぱい毒持ってますけど
外へ出しませんよ まあだから具体的にあの動物のようにということは言いにくいんですけど
人間も社会という水の中に生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから社会壊してはならん
わがままで だから非道徳的で非倫理的で何が悪いのかというということは言えたものじゃありません
だから人間道徳を守るべきっていうのは
この何て言いますか 言うまでもない
いわゆる疑問は成り立たない
異論が成り立たないことなんです
しかし どうですかね 人間の生き方というのは
道徳に関してはものすごく嫌がるでしょう
ものすごい生ぬるいでしょう
態度は 道徳も曖昧でへんてこりんなものだったら
いわゆる道徳のごとく道徳でないもの
道徳もどきだったら真剣です
こんなことやっちゃうと
自分の立場がなんとかなるぞとかという傲慢になってくると
その道徳はそこを守る
それは道徳じゃないんです
例えばいろいろ宗教でもね
道徳を語っているでしょうし
その中で真剣に守る道徳っていうのは全部非道徳なんです
宗教でありますよ 道徳は
仏教だけじゃなくて あるんだけど
このいい道徳はもうどうでもいい
キリスト教だったら殺すなかれっていうことはね
ちゃんとした道徳ですよ
でもそれが全然関係ないでしょ
ローマ法王たちも軍隊持ってもう戦わせちゃったんで
人を殺されたんだ 殺しちゃったんだ
あれで天国の鍵 その人持ってるんだと
誰に何言ってるんでしょうかね
人間のこと平等で謙虚で
何も悪いことをしない
いることはキリスト教でもちゃんと言ってありますよ
そんなこと置いておいて
カトリック教かプロテスタントか
それはえらい厳しい プロテスタントかカトリックかという
こんな人間がくさりかかってる人間作った考え方でしょうに
その仕切りも人間勝手に作ったもんでしょうに
カトリック教でやっていることっていうのは
一つも聖書にないものでしょうに
しかし 聖書にもない自分勝手に作ったものだけは厳密に守る
本当の道徳はどうでもいいと蹴っ飛ばしちゃうんです
イスラム教も同じでしょう
だから正しい道徳を守るという社会は認めるんです
認めるんですよ イスラム教が広げた時は
ずーっともう中国までもう文化壊して壊して壊して
人を殺して殺して 今このもう中央アジアですかね
もう砂漠になっているところ
昔はすごい豊かでしたけど
その時は仏教でしたけど
全部 中国の半分まで行って
とにかく壊す 殺す それだけの字
それだけで何もわからないんだからドーンと落ちるんです
だから自分の正しい道徳なら
もう人間っていうのはそれは馬鹿にするんですね
仏教でも同じでしょう
南無妙法蓮華経となえるか
南無阿弥陀仏となえるかということにはえらい厳しいんですけど
ものすごい厳しいんです
しかし 嘘つきとはならんで
そんなことを言ってもね
嘘も方便でしょうというんで
堂々と だからブッダに説かれた正しい道徳は全部片っ端から潰しちゃって
太鼓叩いて題目を唱えるか
太鼓叩かないで題目を唱えるか
そこで宗派に分かれるんです
お数珠の形はどうするのかとかね
宗派によって形は違うんですよ
禅宗の数珠とかね まあ日蓮のお数珠はそれぞれ違うんです
もういかにバカバカしいかと
例えば日蓮系の数珠ではなんかもうもう日本ぶら下がっているものがあるんですね
それって何てこれって大宇宙ですと
この珠はなんとか何とかです
これこれであって これを大宇宙で
また人間の形ですと それで一つ一つ数えながら南無妙法蓮華経
もうちょっと謙虚に人間になったらどうでしょうか
それは絶対ダメ 安い人間になったらどうです
とんでもない話です そんな邪教は聞きませんよということになるんです
それで数珠をお数珠をこうやって潰すんですね
音を立てて あれは何だ
それで人間の悪をね 煩悩をね
それで潰せるんだ だったら一回で十分でしょうね
それですごく自慢げに立派な音を立ててやるぞとかね
人間っていうのは普遍的で
どんな宗教にも関係なく
人間という人類に対して必要な大事な道徳だけはもう馬鹿にして無視する
だからいつでも正解だけ言うなよという態度なんですよ
間違ったものだったらどんどん言ってくれと
応援してあげるぞと いかに無知かというと
そういうことで 道徳であることが人格者なんですね
別に勉強しているか否か
そんなのはどうでもいいんですよ
勉強しなかったんだからといって
別に生きていられないわけないでしょうに
実際はこの社会は維持管理しているのはすごい勉強している人じゃないでしょうに
ビルを作るんだったらやっぱり設計士も必要し
もうそれを建築家ではなくて
この作る人も必要でしょうし
それでビルが大丈夫ですかね
大丈夫じゃないでしょうね
ずっと管理する必要 掃除のおばさんも必要でしょうに
大きなビルだったらね
でっかい機械やらいろんなもの入ってますからね
それは一つ一つ管理する人も必要でしょうに
その人とは決してビルのビルを使っている人々に顔も合わせないでしょう
例えばエレベーターを管理する人々はね
そのビルを使っている人を知らない
来て 定期的に全部調べて
終わって帰るんです 困ってる人は動かなかったら機能しなかったらそこで管理人に言うだけの話でしょう
だからこの世の中の場合はみんな勉強しておかなくちゃいかんとかね
みんな金持ちにならなくちゃいかんとか
そんな話ではないんです
人間バラバラですごくありがたいんです
能力もバラバラで それこそでもう社会が成り立っているんです
ピアノが弾ける人がいるんだったら
弾けない人はものすごく大事なんですよ
大事さ同じなんですよ
だからピアノを弾けて素晴らしい人間がいたら
ピアノを弾けなくても同じく素晴らしい人間なんですよ
歌える人もすっごく大事なんですけど
同時にあの 何でしたっけ？音痴な人々もものすごく大事なんです
そういうくだらんところで人間が価値入れているんです
道徳はどうでもいいんです
それで歌える人だけ褒め称えて
歌えない人々のことをバカにする
ピアノを弾ける人だけ褒め称えて
弾けない人々はバカにする
たくさん財産を蓄積した人をものすごく褒め称えて
なんとか頑張って生きてる人々のことをバカにする
そうなってくると 人間がもう道徳は関係ないんだと
世は金やと 世はもう才能だと
どうやって人を誤魔化してもう上へ上へ行くのか
それだよと いうとんでもない間違った道になっているんですよ
だからあの このホームレスの人々とかね
まあこのみんな捨てる雑誌とかね
あっちこっちからもう広げて拾って拾って
今なかなかそれもできないようにしていますけどね
またそれすごく綺麗にして
また売ってるでしょうね
大した収入がないでしょ
せいぜい高い値段付けたっても円ですからね
でも 1 日 100冊 200冊は売れませんしね
そこまで拾うこともできないしね
だからやっと生きてるんですよ
でもその人々は努力 素晴らしいことをしているんでしょうかね
どれほど社会のために貢献しているんですかね
だから偉そうに もう自然破壊しながら
ものすごいむちゃくちゃ １００万ぐらい給料もらってる人だけ偉くて
ここら辺である日 すごい背が高いホームレスの人が前でなんか突然模索でフェンスがありますから
そこに何か拾ったんですね
さあ 後ろにいたんだから
何やと見たら空き缶があって
それそれを一つ拾ったんですよ
それで自分のカバンに入れたんです
私はすごい感動したんです
なんて素晴らしい人かと
別にその人は じゃあこっちは汚いんだからゴミを捨ててという意味じゃないんです
その人の場合はもう収入源なんです
生きるためにやってるんです
だからバカにすると罰当たりますよ
それで その人にしたっても
会社の社長にしたっても
必要なのは道徳があるのかないかっていうことなんです
このホームレスの人の面倒を見ている人々なんかは
もういくら苦しくたっても
もう病みつきになっちゃって
もう止められなくなるんです
面倒見るのを付き合うの
なぜかというと そういう人々は本当に人間なんです
一回負けたかもしれませんだけど
ある女の子がもうタイとかあちこち行って
いろいろボランティアして日本に帰ったかな
すごい若いんですけどね
今 20代です 上の公園ですね
テレビの前なので前の話なんですけどね
で 一生懸命自分一人でできるだけのことをやっている
そこであるおじいさんがいて
随分本人がすごい気になってるんですね
気にかかっているというかね
で いろいろ助けてあげようとしても
あまり受けたくはないと
と言ったっても 本人は随分苦しい生活をしている
それで冬なんですけど
すっごく寒いし で 彼女がどこかからボランティアでもらったもんでしょうか？と思いますけど
何かこのなんかピカピカ光ってる
何かもうシーツみたいなのがあって
それはもう体に被っておけば結構あったかくなるんですね
防弾というかね いわゆる防音機能があります
あれ 派手に光るんですよ
あのシーツとは で 雨が降り出しちゃって
彼女はこれ大変だ もう
ということで 本人がすごく寒くて
本人にしたってもね もう傘を差して
もう何人かに配って もうあのおじいさんのところにさっさと
一番困ってるのはそのおじいさんだと
体も弱いんだと おじいさんには居るところもないんですよ
そこで夜傘を差してベンチに座っているんです
冬ですよ あの女の子は一生懸命
おじいさん この傘だけではね
ダメだからね 寒いでしょうに
これ体にずっと巻いておいてくださいと
いりませんというんです
他の誰かにあげてくださいと
女の子がもう負け負けずに
もういろいろもう喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ
もうもうとにかくもうこれ寒いでしょう
風邪引いたら病気になったらどうしましょうか？とかね
一番気に入ったのは 彼女はこういう風にこれ使いますよ
これを全部ずっと頭から被って
こうやればあったくなりますよとかね
自分でやってみたりいろいろするんですよ
あの姿 すごく可愛かったんですね
何のこの頑固じじいや何やという気持ちはまるっきりなく
だからどこかであのおじいさんにしたっても
自分がこんな目になったんだからと言って
来た様になんで目をかけるのかというね
その気持ちもあるんだから
やっぱりそこでもうもう援助を受けなくてももう離れ難いんですね
気になるんですよ どうなっているのかと
だから道徳さえあれば社会は受け入れるということなんで
言いたいのは結局私は
だから簡単に我々人を馬鹿にするんですけど
道徳ない人は堂々と馬鹿にしたってもいいんですけど
人のお金とか体形とかね
そんなもんで褒め称えるのは正しくないんです
そんなものは人間平等じゃない
才能も人間平等じゃない
体形もみんな平等じゃないんです
お金もみんなに平等に付くものじゃないんです
しかし すべての人間に平等に身につくことはできるのは道徳なんです
価値はそちらにあるんです
仏教というのは命より大事にせなさいと
道徳は 命守るか道徳守るかといったら
まあ命捨てなさいよと
それぐらい大事なんです
命かけて守るというのは
まあ仏教的な一般的な言葉なんです
命かけて守るところでしょうかね
今の世界は 道徳は 人を殺すために何とか理由がないのか探しているだけで
人を騙すために何とか理由がないのかと探しているだけであって
社会もそうでしょう 宗教の世界も同じことで
どうすればみんないっぱいもうもう気持ちよくなって
人気があって 自分の方に来るのかと
人気が出るならば どんな悪いことでも
どんな恥ずかしいことでも躊躇なくやる
だから人格者はいない世界で
人格者でない大人が子供にいい人間になれと言っても
子供にわからないんです
だから子供大人になってもいい人間になってないんです
だからこの世の中でみんな平気で人殺すんだったら生きていられないでしょうに
みんな平気で嘘を言うんだったら生きていられないでしょうに
みんな平気で人を裏切るんだったら何一つも成り立たないでしょうに
好き勝手にお互いに嫉妬するんだったら
どうやって仕事でも会社でも社会でもどうやってやるんですかね
他人の足を引っ張ってやるぞとそればっかり考えてるんだったら
みんな それこそ人類の破壊でしょうに
だから人類ね みんな極限にやっちゃうと１日にして破壊するでしょうに
みんな殺生はもう極限に
そんなのは罪でも何でもないんだよと
懺悔しちゃえばいいんじゃないんでしょうかと
私はもう神を信仰してるんだから
そんな非道徳的な話を真面目に信じて実行したらもう世界終わりでしょうに
だからキリスト教にしたっても
この懺悔することと道徳ってどう関わりあるのか説明してないんですよ
懺悔でどんな罪でも許せますかと
はい そうですと言っちゃうでしょうに
すぐに では懺悔してから人間罪を犯したらどうするのかと
そうするとまた懺悔すればいいでしょう
結局は罪を犯してもいいということになってるんです
何もわからないくせにぺちゃぺちゃ物事を言うだけの話ですっごく曖昧なんです
懺悔と道徳の関わりは何なのかと
答え簡単ですよ この道徳を守らなきゃ懺悔は機能しないんだよと
懺悔っていうのは 今まで道徳を知らないうちでやった過ちも知らないんだからといって
間違いは間違いだからね
まあ当時知らなかったんだから
ではそこら辺は許してあげましょうと
でも二度とやっちゃうと
知った上でやっちゃうと
もう懺悔は機能しないということの答えなんですよ
それからっていうのは
人間はたまたま失敗するし
もうたまたま自己管理ができなくなった時って
それぐらいの罪だったら
まあまた懺悔するしかないんだよと
それが懺悔と道徳の関係なんですけど
知るわけないでしょうに
悔い改めなさいとかね
それで天国やとかね だからこの極限に考えれば
道徳一つだけでも みんな非道徳一つだけでもみんな人類やるようになると
それでもう破滅 破壊なんですよ
例えば殺しやめましょう
殺しではなくて まあまあ互いに嫉妬すると
人間平気で互いに嫉妬すると
みんな極限にそれやると仮定してください
それで終わりでしょう
家族も全部 たった一個だけ
だからこの非道徳は危ないということは
極限に想像して考えなくちゃいけないんです
自分のものでないものは取っても悪くないんだと
自分に必要ならと お腹が空いてしょうがないんだったら
何か取って食べたっていいんじゃないですかと
それが極限にみんな守ると
どうなるんですかね それで終わりでしょう
人が何か必要だったら
誰のものであろうと平気で勝手に取ったりしちゃうと
あ このシャツはかっこいいな
これは私は貰うぞといきなり奪ったらどうしますかね
あ この壺 これが私の壺がいいだろう
結構いいんだから はい
もうもう私は取りますからと
店なんか１日で終わるでしょうね
何一つできなくなるでしょう
どんなデパートでも デパート
人々は何のことなく入って品物を持ってそのまま出て行ったら
デパートの人どうするんですかね
あの CD とか売ってるとこで
電気的に音を出すものあるでしょうね
音を立てようが立てなくたって何のことなく持っていけば
[笑い]だから一日で社会が破壊するでしょうに
一項の道徳でも 破っちゃうと
なんでそれに気づかないのかと
この道徳はどれほど命を支えているのかということ
どれほど世界を繁栄させて幸福にしてくれているのかと
具体的に考えてみれば
人間が丁寧に買い物をして
並んでレジに並んで待っていて
お金払って出ていくんだから
でっかいこの畑辺にもあるでしょう
スーパーが24時間やってる
もうそれなりに大きいんだけどね
レジにはもう2人か3人ぐらいですよ
夜になってくると もう一人ぐらい
二人ぐらい 一人で寂しいんだから
それでうまくいってるでしょうに
もし人間はもう物は盗むならば
一人一人のお客さんに対して一人一人店員さんを認定しておかないとダメでしょうね
それでも力強いだったらしょうがないでしょうね
来た人が そうするともう店ができますかね 10
人お客さんが来ると10人店員さん
店員さんの給料は？成り立たないんですよ
一項の品物いたっても
利益としてはほんのわずかでしょうに
だから盗まないということを道徳によって
いかに私は私の財産を守っているし
食べ物を持ってるものを奪われる危険性はないし
社会もそれでうまくいってるし
なのに なんで道徳っていうのはそんなにも軽視して見るのかって
いかに人間っていうのは屁理屈で非合理的かっていうことなんです
だから こんな宗教的な話じゃなくて
単なる社会的な話で問題見れば
いかにブッダが具体的に合理的に喋っているのかとわかるんです
政治家が嘘を言うのはもうそれで正しいとか
嘘を言うのはそいつの仕事なんですけど
あの でも嘘を言ってもあかんというぐらいのことあるんだから
いくらかは国々守られてるでしょうに
例えばイギリスでね まあテロ事件が起きたでしょうに
あんな風に嫌になったら爆弾仕掛けてやるぞという世界になったらどうなるんですかね
[背景音楽]そんなどんな警備やったってもうできないでしょうに
だから道徳を守れっていうことが人格なんです
目の前に効き目があるんだよ
天才的な能力あるエンジニアで科学者であろうとも
二人がいる場合は 会社で雇う場合は誰が雇うべきですか？まるっきり道徳に鈍感で遊びたい放題遊ぶわとかね
嘘を言いたい放題嘘を言う人がいるならば
不倫したい放題不倫するならば
もう一人の科学者がそういうことは何もなく
研究熱心で忠純で研究だけしていると
給料だけを 誰が雇うべきですかね
だから才能がなくても道徳を守っている人を雇うとかなりうまくいくんですよ
それで人格者というのは誰でしょうかというと
道徳を守る人 これまた人類に必要なことで
誰にでもできることはブッダが言っているんです
差別はないんです 普通
俗世間の人格者といえば
まれな人間のことを言っているでしょうね
あの方は人格者であると
そんなまれな人間のことを人格者と思っちゃうと
もう冗談じゃないんでしょう
それは才能について言ってもいいんでしょう
あの才能はまれですと
なかなかみんなにあるわけじゃないんだと
しかし 才能ある人は至っても道徳なかったらもうゴミなんです
社会の だからこの道徳の問題というのは
どんな人間の心にも一応入っているもんですよ
生き続けたいという気持ちがあるんだから
本当は心の中に入っているはずなんです
はずではなくて入っているんです
だからもう無知でもうもう屁理屈でペラペラペラペラ
もう嘘ばっかり言ってるんですけど
道徳的な思考は漏れるんです
でもしっかり喋ってないんです
だから いろんな宗教のどんな宗教の本読んでみたっても
日本にある このまま宗教の特色ひとかけらもない新興宗教いっぱいあるでしょうに
そういう人々が言っているものって
何かどこかどこかで道徳的なことは漏れてはいるんです
日本の場合は堂々と盗むもんだから
他人の考え方 私もすごくこのもう批判しながら喋ってるそういうわけで
結構盗みに来るんですね
もうアイデアがなくて
こちらいくらでも盗んでもいいんだけど
いっぱい一つそれに返してやるぞと
で 非道徳的な目的で使ったりする
だってしまって道徳言った方が人間納得するんだからね
しまって言えないんだから
仏教の世界以外は まあそれは別な話で
とにかく世の中で半端でもうなんとか何とかそれなりに微妙に道徳あるんだから
なんとか我々は生きているんですけど
それももうもうなんとか生きるという
1割  2割ぐらいでしょうね
問題はもう 8割でしょうね
日本の社会も平和な国だ
平和な社会だといっても
無茶問題いっぱいあるでしょうに
問題あるところ全部見てみると
人間らしからぬことをやっていることでしょうに
だから道徳を破ったらそこでもう大変な落とし穴が掘ったことになります
瞬間に というか 地雷を踏んだことになるんです
時々本人だけ潰れる時もあるし
地雷を爆発して周りもやられる時もあります
そういうことで お釈迦様の答えは人間人格者になるということは道徳を守ることであると
次にもしが道徳って何や？と聞く聞きたいかもしれませんだけど
その場合もお釈迦様ちゃんと答え
出している では道徳って何なのかと
当然ながら質問なんですね
それであれやこれやごちゃごちゃではなくて
この十項目あるんだよと
殺すなかれ 盗むなかれとかね
欲しまない 強欲するなかれ
嘘を言うなかれと 悪口を言うなかれと
無駄話するなかれ 異常な欲と異常な怒りをなくしなさいと
変ところにな非論理的な邪見的な妄想思考をやめなさい
それで道徳やと項目でしょう
それも完全なリストなんです
それで全部説明は終わりました
で 道徳的な生き方をすると
人間の心っていうのはものすごい立派になる
それでこの幸福な結果は
この世に留まるものじゃないんです
道徳だけであれば それだけで世界は豊かなんですよ
ものすごく豊かになる
そんなに経済学もあれやこれ
もうまったくいらんものばっかしで
人間楽しくいるんだったら
音楽とかもいらんでしょうに
苦労しながら苦労しながら
１日にして幸福な豊かな社会にはなります
が それはまあただの理想だけで
人間っていうのはもう片っ端からもう頭の根っこから道徳だけはまず否定して
幸せになれないのはどうすれば私は幸せになるのかとまた聞く
幸せになる本ならもういくらでもあるんだけど
もうなりません 基本的な答えは単純だからね
人格者ではないんだから
あなたは 幸せになりませんよと
人格者だったらもう幸せだと
その瞬間から では 答えです
それだけ聞きたくないんだからね
そういうことで まあこの心をすごいしっかりする
そうすると死ぬ時でもしっかりした清らかな心で
死後も偉大なる幸福になります
はい 以上です